hey everyone it's ariana and i think we
can all agree that tiana's beignets and
the princess and the frog look so
unbelievably good today we're making
them at home and they're just as good as
they look
in a mixer stir together a cup and a
fourth of warm milk plus a teaspoon and
a half of yeast and let this bloom for a
few minutes then add a third of a cup of
sugar and one and a half cups of flour
and once that's all combined into a
batter you can add an egg two
tablespoons of butter and an additional
two cups of flour switch over to the
dough hook and mix it for about five
minutes on setting two and then about
two minutes on setting four
after your dough should be all smooth
and fluffy you can also do these steps
by hand but it's just a little bit of a
workout cover your bowl with plastic and
then set it into a warm place to rise
for about two hours
once your dough is doubled in size punch
it down using your fist and then roll it
out to about a third of an inch
thickness
cut out squares to the size you like and
then heat your oil over medium high
adding your beignets in you want to make
sure that it's bubbling so that they'll
fluff up right away make sure to keep an
eye on them because they brown super
quickly and then i finish them off with
a little drizzle of honey and amount of
powdered sugar check out the full recipe
on my instagram where i reply to all my
followers comments
there is absolutely no debate that the
ratatouille from the movie looked
unbelievably good and i'm gonna try and
do that justice today we start off by
slicing one to two zucchinis yellow
squashes
tomatoes eggplants and then get a pan
super hot add olive oil and then one red
bell pepper and one yellow bell pepper i
picked some fresh basil from the garden
and then added it to the peppers along
with a clove of garlic and 28 ounces of
crushed tomatoes next give it a sprinkle
of some salt and pepper and then give it
a little stir
and then we artfully arrange all of our
veggies i started out with a stack of
the four and then swirled it around
until i made it to the end and seasoned
it up with some salt and pepper
the crown and glory that goes on top of
this ratatouille is the herb mixture
it's a little bit of thyme
parsley basil garlic and some salt and
pepper
to this we add about four tablespoons of
olive oil and then spoon it over the
ratatouille
cover with foil and then bake at 375
degrees for about 40 minutes take the
foil off and then bake for 20 to 30
minutes more until you have this
gorgeous color on top
and that's it ratatouille fit for the
critic anton ego himself they were
recreating the spaghetti and meatballs
from that one iconic scene and the lady
in the tram
to make the meatballs mix together a
pound of ground beef with a pound of
ground pork a cup of panko bread crumbs
a half a cup of parmesan salt pepper
two eggs and then we're gonna chop up a
half a cup of fresh parsley
and two cloves of garlic if you smash
the garlic with the back of the knife
the peel comes right off and then you
can mince it up
and add it to the mixture then mix it
all up until it's just combined using
your hands
wow that is a very interesting texture
and then we can assemble our meat
take as much mix as you like to make
whatever size you want and then roll
them up into balls
then add olive oil to a hot pan and fry
your meatballs until they're nice and
golden this helps build the flavor and
then add your pasta sauce
today i'm using this new black truffle
infuse sauce from truff which is
seriously amazing i'm gonna link it in
my bio for anyone who's interested in
trying it
and then simmer your meatballs in the
sauce for about 10 to 15 minutes till
they're cooked all the way through
then put it all together with your
cooked spaghetti and top with more sauce
parmesan and fresh basil
let me know what i should make next and
check out the full recipe on my
instagram
what if i told you you could make these
insanely fluffy and delicious soft
pretzels with only five ingredients
this is not a drill you probably already
have everything you need so let's get it
all you need is 1-3 4 cups of flour i
used whole wheat and then a cup of greek
yogurt that's what gives it the chewy
texture like the ones at the mall you're
also going to add two and a half
teaspoons of baking powder and a
teaspoon of salt and then knead it all
up until it forms the shaggy dough don't
worry about making it totally smooth and
then you're going to want to cut it into
eight sections
once you've got all your sections you're
going to want to roll each one into a
snake look at how fluffy that is and
then twist it into the pretzel shape
it's a little bit of a learning curve
but so fun
add your finished pretzels to a baking
dish and top them with a beaten egg
using pastry brush to get nice and
golden in the oven then sprinkle with
sea salt or cinnamon sugar or whatever
you like bake at 400
degrees for 20 minutes and you're gonna
end up with the perfect soft pretzel
tell me you're not craving this right
now full recipes on my instagram
and follow for more
[Music]
you